thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the emergency maintenance team
of the USG Kelly and responding to your
distress call
[Music]
Isaac Clark
what have you got Isaac half the
ishimura's in the red engines oh the
tramps can you handle it alone thanks to
centrifuge get the fuel running
[Music]
this is senior medical officer Nicole
Brennan Medical is overwhelmed we need
help
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's me
it's all falling apart here
I can't believe what's happening
Nicole
tomon hi everyone welcome to this fourth
Dev stream for Dead Space
on this very day 14 years ago was the
release of the first Dead Space and what
better way to celebrate this than with a
deep dive into the remake of this
fantastic game but I'm getting ahead of
myself my name is Philip and once again
I'm joined by Rahman our creative
director hello everyone and with us back
from our first live stream back in a
year ago we have Jackie and Khalif thank
you for being with us today for this
dream it's nice to finally be in person
definitely is what'd you think of the
trailer I mean it's so cool to see how
far everything has come from you know us
seeing things really really early and
now getting to see you know an almost
finished game like this it's just so
awesome to see all of it start to come
together in this in this bigger way so
really really excited yeah yeah I'm
blown away from going from play test to
finally seeing everything actually come
together as well it just brings up the
Nostalgia and the new game and I'm very
very excited cool nice yeah well as I
said at the start this is our second
live stream with Jackie and Khalif and
then the first one that we did end of
August last year we talked about the
approach that we took for the Remake and
Sean working asset to illustrate our
intentions we followed this up with a
second live stream in March with our
audio director odia slang to explain our
approach on audio that plays such an
important part in the game in the last
live stream that we did in May with Mike
yazigan our art director it allowed us
to go into the details of how the team
is recreating the ishimura for Gen 5.
what did you guys learn exactly from
doing those past live streams
so it was really interesting to be able
to share a working progress or early
assets with the with the community and
get early feedback like we got a lot of
really good feedback from you from
everybody in the community but also
getting feedback like for example on the
audio of the guns or how the the
ishimura did not look Maybe dirty enough
or those kind of things it was really
interesting for us to continue to add to
add and polish the assets we were
building for the for the real game yeah
that transparency is something we
haven't had a really a chance to see a
lot often in the gaming industry so far
so it was really nice to bring the
community in and get feedback not only
with the player Council but with also
like people on Reddit and whatnot yeah
alongside all also kind of giving you
that feedback in real time just how was
the buzz around it because I know a lot
of folks are really excited for this
coming back and now kind of getting more
information and more visuals of seeing
what's happening how did that kind of
play into all of that kind of building
up some more hype for it well for sure
for us it's a way to get the pulse yeah
like what we're making is it is it
something that's exciting players and
for devs like every time that we were
doing a stream everyone was looking at
the boards and any type of social media
trying to follow like okay what are
people saying what are the issues what
are the things that they appreciate so
so it's exciting to be able to have that
feedback much sooner than we usually are
and also not with all button-up assets
that are more marketing yeah and that
sometimes won't necessarily represent
all the effort that the team is having
and putting together to to explain what
are we trying to achieve so I think the
way it was done for us it allowed to
show the behind the scenes a little bit
more uh and show all the passion and
love that the key the team has for for
the game that we're making because like
everybody in the team starting with us
and like yeah everybody at Mojave are
working with us we're all big fan of
dead space and really doing that doing
those live stream having the open
discussion
it's it really helps us to make sure
that we are being true to the original
that not only we are
remaking that space and we're making it
with the eyes of us as fans but that's
also something true for other people
outside of the team that are also fan of
the of the original game that was
something really important for us and I
hope it shows in in what we are showing
today it's very apparent I feel like I
learned that very early on in the player
Council sessions that you guys do care
and you were responsive to critical
comments that we had
um and it's coming from a place of
obviously love and passion for the game
which is nice
yeah and it feels like you're bringing
all of us back in and closer to
development which is a thing I'm sure is
very scary for all of you as well doing
that work and kind of opening up the the
doors in that way but uh but I'm excited
again like this is going to be super fun
and I guess we have a lot more to show
uh during during the stream today
definitely do definitely do so we have
many things to show today so we actually
want to start with a gameplay extend the
trailer that we we're going to look at
um in this extended trailer we'll have
Isaac that's going to be walking through
the engineering deck and it's going to
be his mission is to repair the engines
and to be doing that and to be
fixing something that completely went
haywire will showcase a lot of the
Novelties that we brought to the game
but Roman to kick things off why don't
you talk walk us through the different
priorities that we set very early on on
the project and that have acted as
guiding lights for the production
yes Phil but before doing that I want us
to quickly go back to the original dead
space and just walk you through what we
think where some elements that were
really unique to that experience and
that we really want to
we recreate and pay really Justice to in
the remake of the of the game and the
first one we unprecedented immersion
Dead Space redefine immersion convention
in gaming no ad very few cutscenes
everything geared to other thing players
at the edge of the seats from start to
finish Never Letting Go of the
controller iconic setting inspired by
alien Event Horizon and the things that
space brought a classic survival sci-fi
setting never seen before in game with
this level of quality of course the
gameplay strategic action shooting
monsters in the face was no longer
enough having player think Under
Pressure to survive with satisfying this
moment mechanics was seen as one of the
most unique gameplay decks for the Jones
history
fast forward to today and that space is
back to its roots and better than ever
the first thing we did was to clarify
our design goal defining what it meant
to create a true remake for that space
those four design priorities are true to
the original horror and blockchain
immersion and creative gameplay all
right a great way to set the table for
what's next
so like I said at the beginning we have
a pre-recorded video of a walk through
some of the section of chapter three
inside engineering and it's the first
time that we'll air this and it's a
first look at an extended version of
chapter three so quite exciting
let's have a look
hi my name is Philip dusham senior
producer on that space
today I'm here to give you a first look
at one of my favorite sections in the
game
so we find ourselves here in the
ishumor's hangar at the beginning of
chapter three we're going to make our
way towards the control in engineering
where we'll attempt to restart the
ship's engine
for those of you who remember the
original The Hanger was much smaller
than it is now
we get to explore this location and
literally fly through it before heading
to our destination
navigating between chapters without load
screens or having a camera cutaway is
part of how we've reimagined the
ishimura for the remake
we don't need to rely on the tram as the
sole way to get between chapters
it is now a seamless interconnected ship
[Music]
entering vacuum
[Music]
we've got two lurkers here
you can quickly get rid of them with a
pulse rifle or Isaac's trusty plasma
cutter
there aren't many traditional firearms
on board
survives you may have to improvise and
choose how to take each Necromorph down
we're now entering the ship
we have a lot to show you so let's skip
ahead to chapter three
we've just received a briefing to head
over to the refueling station
to get there we're passing through the
Machine Shop over here
if you needed to backtrack or simply
wanted to explore the ship further
you may encounter a completely different
experience
different enemies
the ambience and lighting may change
this is what we call the intensity
director it keeps the issue more
unpredictable and brings some additional
tension and challenge
the weighted refueling station is just a
little further ahead
[Music]
as you can see some memorable moments
are authentic to the original
we've added tons of graphical
enhancement that supports strategic
dismemberment
using Kinesis will bring that Gondola
over and make our way to the South
refueling station
we need to gain access to the fuel
management office which contains the
power functions for the refueling
station
we can follow that cable to find our way
there
one of the things we try to achieve was
to add more context to the various
objectives to expand on what was there
and bring a bit more detail in depth
where we could
foreign
[Music]
station has no power
we can look for a way to access the fuel
management office
this card should allow us in and we can
now make our way back
damn it Danielson you made it thank God
after the bridge we thought well that's
disappointment I barricaded myself in
the computer core I can hear them but I
don't think they know I'm here I think I
cracked down your wig you're an
engineering right I'll get myself admin
privileges maybe I can help
now that we have access to this room
we're faced with a very tough choice we
could cut power to life support and rely
on air canisters for oxygen but today
we'll play a section without lights
instead
[Music]
foreign
with the power restored the South
refueling station can now be activated
[Music]
in the decontamination room using new
tech we've cranked up the tension
Dynamic smoke creates that thick and
opaque atmosphere that makes you lose
track of the lurkers even when they're
right next to you
foreign
it adds to the claustrophobia the
feeling of being locked in with a pack
of Necromorphs
foreign
it's offline and the yoshima is getting
dragged down to the planet below
we've added so much detail in here
particle effects lighting floating
debris we wanted this room to be
imposing and tell a story at the same
time
it's a lot more impressive and its size
makes it harder to keep track of the
incoming Necromorphs so audio plays a
huge role here in identifying the
direction of threats
with one of the generator modules back
in place we can head to the second one
flying in zero g and not being anchored
to the surface makes spatial awareness
extremely important combat encounters
can quickly become deadly especially
with leapers
and now with the generating modules
powered up the centrifuge is ready to be
activated
clutch engaged the old Personnel fearful
centrifuge restart
I hope you enjoyed this sneak peek at
the new dead space thank you for tuning
in
that was nuts yeah it was [ __ ]
awesome that was wild from the hangar to
decontamination to centrifuge to the
interconnected gameplay to the intensity
director the list goes on the first
thought after seeing that is why the
[ __ ] am I using the tram
the answer is replayability now we can
go back and play multiple playthroughs
with different options you have more
exploration
um it was amazing it's incredible well I
want to talk a little bit about the
intensity director because I think for a
game like this where folks are coming
back to this kind of content one of the
things that people talk about a lot is
like well what's going to be different
in the in the playthrough that I'm going
to have when I go in and go back into a
game like this talk a little bit about
the intensity director and how that's
going to change the way folks are going
to be coming to to this new version of a
game that they might have played before
it was important for us to have
something like to have the right balance
between what's scripted in the game yeah
and what keeps the first the players on
his toes we've obviously and we've seen
it in the trailer we've we've kept a lot
of things scripted like we have to have
those precise jumps there scares at
certain moments and it's important to
have the highs and lows in the intensity
of the gameplay
um but since we're bringing the tram and
the reach reversal throughout the entire
ship we needed something to be able to
fill those section of gameplay and make
sure that there was things that were
surprising the player so that the
tension could go back up and so for us
that was important to find that right
balance and and to figure out a way
to keep the player on the edge when
re-exploring and walking around the ship
and so the thing is that balance does
multiple elements that uh that comes in
it like so yes there is the scripted
golden path moments and those ones every
time you're going to play them they're
going to play exactly the same they're
going to play once and that's it but
even in those sometimes that might be a
Twist like might expect slasher coming
from that band and it's not going to be
there or this kind of those kind of fit
but they're gonna play mostly the same
every time you uh you replay them if
it's a new world through or whatever and
then we have varying degrees of of
systemic events like if it can be just
fights it can be messing with the lights
messing with the sounds there's
different events that uh that we can
play with depending if you're just
moving from a fight to another of or if
you're revisiting a wool section of the
ship it's not going to be the same
basically the way we treat that it we
have an intensity curve
and all the events in the game are
tracked with their level of intensity
and so that allows us to know like okay
the player had already a couple of three
intense fights maybe we're not gonna
throw him another huge fight with uh
with tons of enemies and stuff here in
the next Corridor we're just gonna play
a little bit with the the lights that
are going to Blink and some creepy
Whispers in your ears
and that's it
or that place we really want you to feel
safe and so yeah even the light is going
to be okay no more creepy Whispers
whatever yeah but that went there's
gonna be something weird about that
event and if you get close to it
actually maybe a slasher is going to
spawn and make you jump uh
and all those things will be handled by
the by the intensity director and I know
you also talked about this you know
pre-stream and and pre-pre-conversation
was you know even the slashers are going
to be a little bit different when you
see one as opposed to the other talk a
little bit about that because I thought
that was super cool too yeah so that's
something in the original like all the
slasher they already had some kind of
job when they were humans about the ship
like depending on which Bridge you wear
you why you wear sandliners or medical
guys or whatever so that's something we
definitely kept from uh from the
original but the thing on that we wanted
to add bits even more personality to the
slashers and makes you really like every
time you're gonna shoot a slasher you
would like you to feel like it's a
different different guy and so on top of
giving them jobs and different clothes
and stuff like that we also gave them
ethnicity because the shimra is really
has a diverse crew and we wanted that to
also show on the on the slasher so no
it's really it feels every time it's a
it's a new guy and it's new you can
really believe no playing the game we're
trying to reinforce the immersion around
that like yeah those monsters
they used to be the crew so so should we
feel sorry now
for the slashes that we take out yeah we
were like oh that person was the cook on
the ship you gotta go exactly yeah
I'm good I have friends I have friends
who can't but we're not going to talk
about that during the stream but yeah a
lot of other conversations about that
for sure I think we should talk also
about audio audio is obviously the
massive staple it's What drew me in
initially to dead space and really kept
me that whole Intrigue
um in this trailer and decontamination
for example we have the increased fog
like the dynamic fog that you can't
necessarily always see where enemies are
coming from which is really interesting
because of its more audio and you have
to really listen to what you're looking
for and we see that again in the
centrifuge which by the way is [ __ ]
massive it's huge if I love how you're
showing the original game because you
recall like these different areas and
you imagine these huge environments but
now look looking at what the Remake is
it just mind-blowing honestly and it's
much darker which I grilled you guys a
lot about that
I remember that yeah but I really really
like that since these spaces you still
have the smaller spaces enclosed for
that claustrophobic feel which is true
to the original but you also have these
very very large rooms now that are
extremely built out grittied down very
gritty looking and dark and immersive
but you don't know where ADS are
necessarily coming from because of the
intensity director it's not just the
same vent every single time which is
great because then you have to utilize
your audio and really listen for where
ADS are coming out
I love that aspect and I like
decontamination it's much scarier in my
opinion now there's a lot to like yeah
definitely well you touched on a lot of
points that that were points of interest
for us so audio that we had like I said
odv that went in and explained how we're
trying to recreate in one of the past
streams and it is something that like
with such groundbreaking I think in the
initial game it was so well done but the
addition of the occlusion and making
sure that we under understand where is
the sound traveling from when you're
navigating the ship to really hear the
threats and say like oh no that creature
just spawned behind me but I have
someone in front of me now like
what should I do yeah and we do play
around with that like in the scripted
sequences but also the intensity
director like Aman said there's a lot of
events that are either foreshadowing
events that may lead to something or not
or post shadowing like if the enemy
decides to jump through a vent and walk
away and run away you'll hear that enemy
travel within within the world so so if
he's trying to actually run away after
you because you ran away you saw him and
we're like no [ __ ] it
oh that's awesome
so it plays such an important part and
with the music with the sound effects of
the guns and everything and it's it's
we're getting to a place where it feels
good it feels right when you're
listening the right tune the Right Mix
it's always something that we do until
the very end the mix of every sound
element
um but the team's done an amazing job
and it's great yeah uh real real quick I
got to talk about Isaac having a voice
in this too which I think is really
really interesting a lot of folks are
going to be excited to see how that's
going to play out in the game too talk
about how important it was to add that
layer to to this game too so yeah
definitely early on that was a that was
a huge deal the discussion around Isaac
voice like in one of our first conceals
we spoke about that and that's for us
I'm still mad that I wasn't the voice of
Isaac I'm just I'm still salty about
that I didn't get that role I raised my
hand a lot
so all of our thoughts about that was
like so yes we're making that space But
Who's Isaac who's that guy and thinking
about that space that space two that
space three
for us Isaac Clark it's really it's
going all right it's the the actor
that's playing Isaac in that space 2 and
that space three then give his voice to
Isaac in that space to him that's
basically so the point of which in the
team we call him Governor Clark
he's the guy and so
going back to that space there were
elements that we wanted to uh to enhance
in some of of narrative and one of those
was how Isaac as a character
why is he coming to the Ishima what's
his relation with the other characters
around and also give him a bit more
urgency to have him a little bit more
passive like when you enter an area and
you get Ammon or Kendra telling you
everything you exactly have to and right
you're supposed to be the engineer
that's your role like you're supposed to
be the guy that knows how to actually
make do stuff and get out of that alive
so for all those reasons early on who
started to think about okay we should
go back to gonna write
now if that guy the Isaac also in that
space one
and we should give him a voice
and now that's allowed us to unlock all
those different elements around giving a
bit giving him a bit more personality
and agency in what he's doing stuff but
the one issue of course was with horror
because isolation is a huge element of
the aura in that space and it's dilemma
like when you're in the dark and you
have to go in the basement and you're
looking for the lights
no no you don't fight the [ __ ] riots
and you start to talk to yourself
because it reassures you yeah and that's
was definitely something we didn't
wanted for that space we didn't wanted
Isaac to start to talk when he's alone
because that would break the oral
element so we have that one rule
that is almost true across the game we
maybe break it once or twice not more
which is Isaac only talks when he's
being talked to he only answers I to get
to Medical you see the barricade almond
starts talks to you and Isaac will
answer and say yeah that's the [ __ ]
barricade I have to blow it and it's
Isaac that's going to come with the plan
of what to use in where to find those
things to blow the barricades
but then once that communication is done
when you're alone in medical while
you're alone in medical and it's not
going to command what he sees and he's
gonna shut the [ __ ] up and that's
something that's really important for us
and I think it really improves the
immersion because also it gives
reactions to Isaac to uh to elements
that
we're feeling weird if he was not
reacting to or if no emotion about
what's happening yeah that's awesome I'm
super excited to see that come come to
life because I know when I am scared I
do really really dumb things I talk to
myself I beat box so Isaac hopefully
will beatbox and when he's scared so
we'll see how that works cool you'll
hear him Grunt and uh like throughout
the exhaustion and when he's tired
you're gonna hear him yeah paying when
he's hurt and everything through the
Ally system yeah but no he's not going
to mumbled himself like you do okay good
good good good good good on him for sure
okay well it wouldn't be a celebration
without showing some more awesome stuff
for the Dead Space fight I'd like to
introduce our friends at limited run
games
Alina Jared great to have you both join
us do you love Dead Space of course you
do I'm Jared from limited run games and
I love Dead Space too and I'm not the
only one here who does for example to my
right you're left my friend
Alina hi I'm Alina from limited run
games and we are super excited to show
you what we have for Dead Space fans you
told us you wanted a dead space
collector's edition and we listened and
you said what you wanted most of all was
this the Isaac helmet and holy crap it
happened isn't this amazing and we're
gonna get to it in just a minute yes
it's the most exciting part but there's
also some really great other stuff in
this collector's edition we want to show
you and for more on that Elena so we're
super excited to talk about the
components of this dead space
collector's edition there's so many
awesome things I can start with so we've
got a four inch premium marker statuette
it's beautiful it's going to be heavy
and we can't wait for you guys to put it
on your desk we also have a steel book
included which has the Dead Space logo
in Isaac's silhouette on the back okay
totally interrupting here but I want the
embroidered ishimura three inch patch I
want to stick it on something I don't
know my jacket my hoodie here my
forehead I don't know where you're going
to put it I don't know you could put it
on anything maybe a backpack a dog a dog
a pig dinosaur yes Pizza yes don't eat
it but it might taste good yeah getting
back to this apparently we also have a
lithograph of some sort yeah we do we
also have a lithograph print encased in
a bi-folding portfolio it also has foil
stamped logos on the front of it it's
going to be awesome I want to get my
hands in this marker enamel pen you can
stick it in your Crocs and your bulletin
board in your wall you can stick it
anywhere you want to and a soundtrack
and four mini posters and now what you
really came here for that's right the
Isaac helmet look at this thing of
beauty it lights up it's big it's Hefty
and it's absolutely enormous not only is
it big and Hefty and enormous it's also
adjustable now I have a truly colossal
Noggin like a big old fat head and this
thing watch this
goes right on it that's right Elena is
this an improvement uh I think it looks
very good you do well you know what I
mean okay so once again it's adjustable
so it'll fit any size head or almost any
size head my head probably your head
definitely a leanest head but you're not
going to put it on my hair
so yeah there's a lot of love and
passion that went into the creation of
this helmet it's based on in-game
sculpts our team worked directly with
the character artist to get the paint
shape and feel just right you can feel
the love that went into every texture of
this helmet folks this is a spectacular
collectible I really really hope you're
going to enjoy it we're happy to offer
it Elena tell folks where they can get
it today you can pre-order the Dead
Space Collectors Edition for a limited
time on limited rungames.com you can get
it for PlayStation 5 Xbox and PC friends
this is one spooky piece of headgear we
hope you enjoy it
bye bye bye thank you Alina Jared
everyone at limited owned games this
looks great thank you for putting this
together what are your thoughts my
eyeballs immediately gravitate towards
the LED helmet I'm I'm more looking at
the the marker I love small things you
can put on your desk and kind of show
your fandom and nerd them in that way
and and weirdly I like the propaganda
poster stuff like you know kind of
getting a chance to see like inside the
world of the game in those kinds of ways
that stuff always makes makes you really
happy so are you gonna wear the helmet
though I am yeah
I love that I love that I love that also
following some of the streams we saw the
comments from fans that like they've
liked the shorts that we had the hoodies
that we've shown at the different live
streams and they were asking where they
could get it so like we're happy that
working with different teams internally
we actually were able to spin out a shop
that's going to be coming soon so you're
going to be able to get sort of the
shirts like mine like Romans and not
prototype but there will be a multiple
shirts with these stuff like that so
keep on the lookout for the store coming
soon right yeah all right time to wrap
this up
huge shout out to our teammate motive
and all of the collaborators that have
helped us bring this remake to you all
and a big big big thank you to everyone
working on that project whether it's
Automotive or all of our partners but
also to everybody in the community
council thank you very much for all your
feedback for helping us make that remake
a true that space experience and to
everybody in the larger community that
tune in during our live stream that gave
us feedback that also helped us shape
that remake thank you very much we're
lucky to have the community council
that's with us today for the anniversary
live stream so thank you all for your
presence your feedback has been very
useful all throughout production so
being with us since conception it's been
great thank you if you like what you've
seen today and are excited about the
return of dead space on PC and next-gen
consoles the game is available for
pre-order or you can mark your calendar
for January 27 2023. we're eagerly
looking forward to that date
be sure to follow our different social
channels to stay up to date on all of
that space related information so you
don't miss anything leading up to our
launch Jackie Khalif thank you for being
with us today excited to play some more
of the game I mean it is time now for us
to stomp out some necromores I'm excited
for that I'm excited to check out the
ishimura and all the goodness that you
put in so it's time it's time to get it
on I'm really high for lunch ready it's
about time oh yeah
thank you everyone I hope that you've
enjoyed the stream today and looking
forward to showing more of the game to
you all
this is the emergency maintenance Clark
what have you got Isaac shimura's in the
red engines Hull the triumphs can you
handle it alone place the centrifuge
this is senior medical officer Nicole
Brennan Medical is overwhelmed we need
help
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
detected
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Humanity will be made
with
over that
I think
it's all falling apart here
believe what's happening
Nicole